[Music]
hello everyone this is viewers Choice
and Grandmaster Dennis portion we're
going to look at some games weight
recently
and not so recently so it's gonna be a
mixed bag alright and let's start with
this game egg or cop plays the ones I
don't know who is the person d4 Knight
f6 c4g 693 5 I'm always happy to see
this because even though there are some
drawing lines in the Grunfeld
but it's always an exciting opening to
play C takes D 595 fee for all very
natural Knight c3 takes Bishop g7
neither three castles now castles even
though it's played by many players it's
not so good fact it was played in a game
recently in the World Cup between aronia
and do both but I still feel that c5 is
the best move here because you want to
jump out with your queen as quickly as
possible and put pressure on this I'll
see a little pawn on c3 so I think this
is a miss or at least a little bit of an
inaccuracy castles Bishop e2 that's very
good c5 Bishop e3 now Bishop e3 is
basically giving back well which one
which shouldn't have been given back I
should have just castled and after
Bishop g4 y it has Bishop e3 knight c6
ideas are always buried with d5 and this
is a huge advantage for a white the only
question would be maybe Queen a5 but
then again white can play Bishop e3
Queen takes c3 rook c1 and what is going
to take this c5 pawn and have big
compensation that he shouldn't get
so that's one of the one of the big
reasons you need to play see five here
but Queen a five and if Bishop e2 you
can already attack the center which you
couldn't do if you castle so castles
Bishop e2 c5 Bishop e3 Queen a five
again it's a very standard position
Queen b3 but Queen b3 is very wrong mice
Queen b3 so wrong in this position
what's wrong with Queen b3 yeah it's
just wasting time and also it doesn't
block this diagonal so black has a very
powerful move here
yeah just take just take instead of
knight c6 just take would have been very
good because this would ruin the center
for whites and actually the only thing
white had going for him is the center so
Knight d4 Knight c6 and I would even
claim that black is slightly better in
this position so knight c6 was played
which wasn't a great idea castles and
now white is again
in contention rook b8 Mughal d8 I don't
like one of the reasons I have bad
memories the second thing is this f7
pawn can become a real big weakness rook
D 1 C takes d4 Knight d4 which is
terrible because you need to take with
the C pawn you're playing for these
healthy Center pawns and then you can
get better with white but if you just
destroy your own center that will cost
you 95 okay
like doesn't really want to exchange
stuff at for 9 G for the ship c1 should
be seven h3 well there's no Queen takes
b7 because black would just take on c3
and have a pleasant position these
pieces on e 2 e 2 and C 1 are very
passive
so it's minimum equals for black but it
should be objectively better h3 Bishop
a4 Oh tactics green a3 9 8 6 what queen
a3 just saved in white because there's
no bishop d1 y just takes the Queen
in a 396 rook d3 v6
okay I like b6 stabilises the Queen just
defends it but on the other hand black
was doing something that he shouldn't
have done what is that think that black
did that he shouldn't have done in this
position what did black misplace badly
which piece got badly misplaced in this
position yeah can you please your raise
your hand yeah yeah denied on h6 is
terrible it's not doing anything there
and it rather beyond anywhere on the
board there's no place it wouldn't
rather be it would rather be on a one
down on h6 it just doesn't feel well
they're so Bishop III that is why I'm
not sure that why it is so much worse
anymore
it's roughly equal complicated I'm not
not sure that with this knight black
can't pretend to be better bishop f8
black is being tricky what does black
want to play in this position next
me five of course just defending the
pond and also being tricky planning to
play e5 f given the chance and that that
would be a double attack as the Bishop
hits on the Queen and the night at the
same time but why doesn't want to
blunder
a piece of place Queen B to green a six
which is a strange move because if you
can don't put your queen in a battery
because that could never turn out well
rook D - Queen B seven but it seems
black survived a scare
Bishop f3 rook c8 g four in g4 I give
high marks ooh because it asked the
question where is this Knight headed and
I'm just gonna play g5 and then a piece
if you don't do something about it
so black played King g7 out of
desperation g5 98 f5 and there are two
colors here but I rather be White Queen
c7 and the tragedy that the tragedy here
is that f6 is impossible because of 96
check and we take everything otherwise
blacks position is pretty rough Queen c7
Knight eat - now that's a bit passive
right and what son cares for it wasn't
there wasn't really a big need for that
c4 yeah another little trick by white
would be a great idea because green c4
runs into what yeah just checkmate
double checkmate
you don't only make you double check
mate the best he has the knight and the
Queen as the magnificent - just kills
the black King on g7 and yeah after c4
black would be in big big trouble knee
resigning
laughter Queenie five which would be
natural and again runs into something
super above knight c6 of course and
again the Magnificent duo wins
so instead white played 92 which is not
a great move therefore AB six finally
black could say C four still could work
but I don't think it's gonna get played
nope Bishop g4 which again not a great
move what else could we do here
yeah almost everything but we still need
to find the plan even if we're winning
you still need a plan I believe why does
winning but still not f4 yes and
actually that's an important trait of a
chess player you have to admit your
mistakes sometimes and go back to e6
because as Eric Rosen would say that
night on e6 would be an octopus and we
love octopuses if there are ours and not
our openings we hate we hate enemy
octopuses Bishop g4 rook takes D to
Queen takes D to and I'm not happy
anymore for white I think they're just
worse why because our King side is a
little bit loose and we're going to play
for the pay the price for that route d8
Bishop d4 Bishop b5 the last three moves
by black were really sensible putting
pressure on this e to night again this
rook is putting pressure on d4 so this
is getting very very bad suddenly for
white okay f3 h5 I don't know h5 I've
wouldn't have found not that it's bad
but I'm not sure it's good
g5 takes Knight takes h6 and I think I
spotted why it's not so much fun because
Queen g5 might be a little bit
irritating black still has this move of
Bishop e8 but who wants to play Bishop
e8 I don't want to play Bishop e8 so I
think h5 was a bit hasty black could
just try to activate the Queen somehow
bring it to c4 or something still feel
that is getting good for black but h5
was a bit too much takes takes Knight f4
finally bringing the knight to e6 also
hitting on g6
rogue d69 takes g6 but again it turns
out terrible as I realized he needs to
bring his knight up Knight takes a fait
Queen f7 oh my god what's going on
96 Queen age - okay so white one apiece
so after three four moves but it was
swinging back and forth it was kind of
close to being very good for black now
it's totally winning for white again in
b7
there should be three good just keep
your extra piece green takes e4 oh my
god again black is having lots of
threats rugby one queen bee one
so maybe black has some sort of
compensation in this position King F -
Queen Bee one King g3 but this was a
good plan trying to tuck away the king
and the King feels quite safe on g3 with
with the watchful eye of the e3 bishop
so rook d1 King H for Bishop c6 rook F -
rook h1 rugby - now I always tell my
students if your queen is hanging defend
your queen
don't bother attacking any other pieces
just bring your queen to g3 that's much
much better than starting to goose chase
the other Queen because that can only
lead to trouble
Queen e1 pin f2 not g4 King takes g4 in
d1 King gauge for d3 and white there's
still a piece up but I can see a lot of
black pieces swarming around the white
king queen g3 queenie for g4 and rook f1
Bishop f2
Brooksie one it's getting confusing King
age five takes takes yeah
like didn't want to get checkmate a twin
Queen g7 so black took six rook takes c3
ship h4 Bishop f3 check ow
that's nasty we should be for King g4
you should pass three can you have to no
draw well I don't know I don't know I'm
confused already
it was better and not sure if why it is
much better anymore because this bishop
is a monster it's different to an
octopus but it's still a pretty good
piece 98 King g6 King g1 yeah why
totally lost control of this game
rook d25 rook d7 rook c4 Shiva - okay
four okay so black is eating all the
funds can get six six four don't blunder
Oh the rook the rook is gone and then
that will be gone and the game is gone
all right so white resigned
okay so let's look at this game by rote
coughs ki Noah Dorfman Morial let's see
what's in store the sicilian assist so
the end of one kind and the night off
stylish this should be three e 5 clearly
the best move here
some people played east six in the past
but just to name a very very famous
hungarian player bail up a rainy and he
invented this brilliant tactical
variation of g5 g takes f5 e takes f5 d5
G takes f6 sometimes or even Queen f.3d
for long castles 97 and you wouldn't
guess what's one of the main moves in
this position I don't accept positional
moves I just say this up front
the ship takes d4 so Bishop takes d4 for
petty is two positional he takes with
the rook because he believes that
domination is more important than pieces
and won many many games with his own pet
line and this was later on taken up by
Judit Polgar and she actually beat many
good players including Vishwanathan
Anand so this is a very very
bloodthirsty line which I like pretty
much I'm sure Todd would like it too so
anyways Witkowski played a five against
mr. anonymous Knight f3 obviously
there's many moves here Knight B 3 is
the classical one and should be better
not if 3 is a little bit timid and I'm
not a big fan even though I played this
move myself B 5 B 5 seems a little bit
early why is b5 too early in this
position can anybody help me with that
well yeah now potentially there could be
sacrifices but not yet now mostly the
fact that this diagonal opened up and
usually white can use that with a 495
has happened in the game and this is
kind of a nasty nasty knight on d5
because you can't even take it
because Queen d5 and you can wave
goodbye to your rook on a8 because I'm
just gonna gobble that thing so Knight
d7 a very very nice classical no I Dorf
move they should Knight eggs before
Bishop c4 though would have been
powerful because in general in this
position there's only one squared that
matters and that's the d5 square just
taking a pawn for the sake of taking
upon is not a great idea and rutkowski
shows that and immediately reinforces
his pressure on the d5 square now
already black is out-powering white on
the d5 square if I would go back
it could take take and maybe in the near
future castle play F 5 F 4 and Black has
very nice counter play for the
sacrificed pawn so all in all I think
mr. NN should have played Bishop c4 and
for one thing put pressure on d5 and
maybe hinting on f7 a little bit so
night b4 was played there should be
seven Bishop c4 I think I move too late
Bishop takes e4 because white white
loses this important efore pawn which is
usually not a good sign
in the night or Fourier ssin Castle
Queen c8 just taking away this square
white Queenie to a five-night a to
Bishop e7 and already I think black is
clearly better he has this Center
he has the center he has all the control
on the important squares so this is like
slight minus plus for Black Knight c3
this should be seven rogue d1 Castle 95
and now white is helplessly trying to
get control over the d5 square but it's
not going to work now I have six and
already Volkov ski is booting out that
d5 Bishop this should be three eight six
now it wouldn't change a thing if white
would take on b7 in takes b7 because in
the near future
I'll be able to play d5 and if you're
desperately clinging to that square I
can go room b8 them put pressure on the
b2 pawn yeah so this is very pleasant
for black 95 Bishop b3 eight six I like
this age six move why is the h6 move
such a great move in this situation
yeah it just stops Bishop g5 and also
helps this night to be stable and you
will have an eternal control of the d5
square and that's what matters in these
kind of positions Queen d2 Queen f5 no
peanut five is fine but black could even
go queen g4 and that's almost deadly
because after Queen e2 I can think about
exchanging but okay I don't want to give
away my beautiful b7 Bishop but already
after like rook c8 might has trouble
moving around with his pieces so clean
f5 was played 91 d5 those tanks start
rolling and then it's gonna get much
worse Queen d3 mean h5h three we should
basics c4 I don't like c4 because if you
have a worse position at least try to
stay still a little bit passive so you
can maybe defend but oh I just missed
this
yeah d4 just wins so that's not good
alright so c4 has to be played which is
a bad sign D takes bishops we should
take c4 rook the 8th and that loses a
piece so it's gonna be over very soon
takes takes yeah yeah that what you're
saying oh okay
he can move to c2 but then I take on d1
take again Bishop takes c4 takes and the
sneaky Queen on h5 takes to d1 rook so
he has to take some material yeah I'd
rather sacrifice just like why did yeah
I mean I I would rather sacrifice my
queen than just to give away a free
piece because if I sacrifice my queen I
might built a fortress if I'm very very
lucky but if I just give away a free
piece there's no guarantees I can
survive that game so in this way what
was doing the right thing but I'm still
not happy positionally I'm cringing
while I ca for c4 together so rook da
takes takes we should take say six but
still this is the best practical chance
and that's true ninety-five Bishop c5
Knight f4 King F 1 C 1 B 4 well when
you're aiming for fortresses you're not
supposed to start exchanging and
changing the structure in general try to
stay put and hope for the best
that's what you can do when you're a
queen down for some material like a rock
and peace before takes Knight takes h3o
and the tactical ploy Bishop e2 well if
takes I assume black ones
kingi one Queen g4 check and he's just
going to take the B for Bishop now if
you wonder if the knight can block well
it can but then I check you again and I
will even take your rook because it's a
left undefended King G 2 is the same
deal as King G 1 I'll play queen g4 and
I take you again on b4 you should be -
Queen h4 another double attack
and this is just too much black is
slowly winning the game as he takes
everything in Devon Bishop f1 Bishop h2
Queen takes e4 and after Queen b5 white
resigned alright so let's look at one of
Ben Simon's own game which I can hear
someone nodding heavily the background
is the holiday bash but it was actually
played in st. Louis so that's wrong
let's flip the board so we can have a
good view of this game
efore e5 so Ben Simon played Humphreys
and this is a Spanish actually very rare
Spanish Bishop c5 I've barely seen this
move I've seen Bishop c5 immediately
that the idea of c3 f5 and with wild
complications this is actually known to
be the favorite of Hector Johnny and he
had pretty good results with this with
black it's not that great but it's
playable ok a six Bishop a4 Bishop c5
this move is pretty rare
castles Knight f6 now we transpose back
to the classical Archon gask lines but
this could have been an original
position if black plays black plays d6
and Bishop d7
oh not there d7 so Knight f6 D 3 D 3
actually I'm wondering if I can take on
c6 d takes and Knight takes e5 that's
quite possible as after Knight e4 Queen
e2 maybe Queen d5 hmm actually this
whole still holds but oftentimes elites
players and play in this move order of
playing b5 first Bishop b3 and Bishop c5
and I guess that's one of the reasons
they do this move order that they're not
that sure of this Bishop takes c6 so d3
these six h3 Bishop d7 Bishop d7 is a
very nice developing move but can
anybody help me to find an even stronger
move in this position
Knight d4 is not quite possible because
you're pinned so you can't do that
b5 yeah and if I play Bishop b3 age 6
yeah not a 5 yeah yeah age 6 could be
interesting and it's very typical just
to take away this square but Knight e5
is even stronger as it has this brutal
threat of taking away White's Bishop
therefore getting the bishop pair
advantage which usually gives you a
slight advantage if you play black but
Bishop d7 is a normal move Knight c3 94
notice that this B 595 plan is still
valid for a long time until white plays
c3 this Knight e5 ID is possible because
if I play b5 now I can post my bishop to
c2 or if I'm cheeky I can play Bishop b3
and after Knight a5 Bishop c2 or if I
even want to punish you I can take take
and b4 fork but after Knight c3 b5 is
still possible what an ID for is a very
clean move getting rid of all these
nasty pieces this a for Bishop and this
knight on f3 and usually this should
equalize takes takes Bishop g5 h6
provoking successful provocation g2
except 695 castles actually I really
like this spawn sacrifice because the
side black is trying to play on is the
king side so he is trying to check made
there and if you take some pawns in
front of your own King I say thank you
thank you for your donation 95 room g8
and rook Jade is very good just lining
up lining on
the G line hitting on the g2 pawn and
threatening this little idea of Queen
takes h3 sir King gauge to f5 and this
looks very nice with black even if your
computer will cry in this position that
you have pawn down you're upon down and
what's wrong with you turn off your
computer use your brain you're the only
one attacking in this position so black
must be better or at least have a decent
amount of compensation in this position
ID for Bishop d4 Knight b4 is a good
move whenever you're defending it but
you're a pawn up try to exchange off
some pieces because that will make your
life somewhat easier Bishop d4 c3 Bishop
a7 Queen b3
setting setting up a little trick
because if let's say I take on e4 too
early how can we punish that Knight b6
of course and that would be a sad day
for black that's white we just take this
Queen and have a good afternoon but
black sees that in place King b8 Queen
d1 now this doesn't make make any sense
at all so Queen b3 is fine it's a good
little trick connecting the two rooks
but going back just doesn't make any
sense
I would rather play something along the
lines of Queen e2 trying to defend the
g2 pawn after let's say Queen g6 f3 now
this looks very ugly for white but I'm
not losing yet and that makes me feel
relatively happy letter check there's
this move and because of this Queen
being here I can still kind of defend
that h2 square which will be pivotal if
black goes rook g5 and attempt sacrifice
I'd still say obviously rubgy file
doesn't work right now because the 97 i
takes f5 so to give you a better idea
instead of check maybe rubgy 7 would be
better just defending against this and i
jump and the plan is just a simple
double linked actually tripling of the
rooks and the queen and this should be a
brilliant position for black so Queen B
3 King b8 Queen D one Queen g6 that's
very good
hitting on anything the G 2 spot
immediately G 3 and now pal Bishop takes
F 2 because there's no rock takes F 2
the screen takes G 3 just wins the rook
and wins the game
so Humphries rejected that played Queen
f3 the ship takes G 3 I like the
decision of taking with the bishop and
screen takes G 3 could end up in a
boring winning position with an extra
pawn but it will take some time to win
but if we keep our queen and keep on
attacking it will be a much shorter
struggle engage one Queen g5 when Queen
takes f5 was a big mistake as Queen d2
wraps it all up as this threat of Queen
age 2 it's hard to defend and that's how
Ben Simon won this game thank you so
much this was viewers lecture
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]